ta voiture mais en tout cas ce matin une
campagne de sensibilisation contre
l'homophobie et la transphobie et l ens
et la transphobie été lancée sous
l'égide de l'éducation nationale le
principe est présenté sur le site du
ministère de la manière suivante
prévenir les manifestations de
l'homophobie et de la transphobie
ordinaire dans les établissements
scolaires et faire acquérir à tous les
élèves le principe de l'égalé dignité
des personnes pour assurer un climat
scolaire sera pour tous dit d'une autre
manière par jean michel blanquer europa
ce matin cela donne ceci lutter contre
l'homophobie et la transphobie c'est
évidemment lutter pour les valeurs de la
république pour lutter pour le droit à
la différence le fait qu'on doit
accepter chacun comme il est et
permettre à chacun son épanouissement
c'est une sorte d'évidence et c'est
l'école qui le premier lieu avec la
famille où on doit dire c'est évident ça
prévient que nous l'aidions est bon on
va le dire avec une grande force en
faire un tour de table très rapide
bernard de la villardière je crois que
vous avez un film en soute sur ce sujet
salomao fait le mot phobie dans le monde
faisant dire qu'on se rend compte qu'en
france on est quand même énormément de
progrès grâce à dieu bien sûr la média
71 et adam mondou
l'homosexualité est condamné condamnable
et huit pays dans lesquels on est
passible d'une condamnation à mort
est-ce qu'il vous semble qu'en france
l'école et le bon lieu pour enseigner
soucis ou ce oui ça peut l'être mais il
faut pas oublier la famille je suis
content qu'il ait dit que sa famille est
importante aussi je sais pas à quel âge
se fera cette ses cours d'éducation de
sensibilisation roulage amélie s'est
aussi joint d'accord voilà après qui va
le faire comment etc
moi en tant qu d'affichage mais en tant
que la match race est vigilant et qui le
fait comment voilà et je pense que on
est dans la sexualité l'orientation
sexuelle comment on dit aujourd'hui même
si je n'aime pas beaucoup ce terme parce
qu'ils n'ont pas d'orientation on est
soit homosexuel soit hétérosexuel enfin
la nature des sites pro ou enfin c'est
pas tellement un choix contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait dire
et donc voilà la manière dont on
communique sur ces questions président
de l'essence est très important
d'ailleurs certains psy vous disent
qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup d'angoissé
adolescents parce que tout d'un coup on
leur présente la chose en dire un an
mais tu peux choisir
ben non tu choisis pas cessé selon data
nature la nature et c'est aux parents
évidemment la compagnie des vigilants de
voilà et donc j'ai peur qu'on dit
responsabilise les parents dans ce
combat contre l'homophobie qui est
injuste condamnation va centrer mais
vous n'avez pas l'impression que jean
michel blanquer se renie un tout petit
peu parce qu'ils avaient décidé que
l'école c'était vraiment un lieu où on
apprend et que ça c'est plus ça relève
plutôt fictivement de l'éducation
familiale plutôt que les questions
nationales ce genre de sujets là moi
j'ai trouvé que sa déclaration était à
la fois enfin qui coupent personne ne
peut ne pas la partager
et en même temps il ya quelque chose
d'un peu creux en dix ans les valeurs de
la république s'était rap en moi il me
semble quand même que la meilleure façon
de désarmer les préjugés et l'homophobie
n'est d'un préjugé
c'est la culture générale c'est
justement l'éducation de l'intelligence
de la sensibilité et qui permet ensuite
de surmonter un certain nombre de divers
gration ça et ça à mon avis on ne dirait
pas avec des enseignements de théories
condé espèce de leçon de morale comme on
faisait des leçons de morale sous la
iiième pas envie que ça me paraît enfin
mon avis ça me paraît pas très efficace
et opérant mais peut-être je me trompe
patrick pelloux moi je crois que vous
vous trompez vous adore on a trompé
parce que c'est pas creux de dire d'un
coup que le ministre de l'éducation
nationale disent je vais remettre les
valeurs de la république
évidemment vous avez des quartiers ou
d'un coup les valeurs de la république
elles sont faites par la famille par le
collectif par la mairie etc
vous avez des quartiers qui sont
totalement à l'abandon où les valeurs de
la république sont remises en cause par
des communautarismes religieux je pense
notamment à l'islam radical qui a assez
brigade maintenant de la morale dans la
rue etc etc faut lutter c'est pour ça
que blanc caire moi je soutiens ces
faits sont largement homophobe largement
homophobe c'est pour ça et exactement
c'est pour ça que cette idée plus on
dira qu'il faut remettre les valeurs de
la république auprès des élèves des
collégiens des lycéens mais même du
cours élémentaire plus le vivre ensemble
sera tolère moi je suis complètement
d'accord avec cette mesure parce que
tout ce qui permet de faire avancer la
tolérance et de lutter parce que écouter
faut arrêter de se leurrer la l'un des
endroits les plus intolérants qui soit
ce sont les cours de récréation ça tous
les pédopsychiatres toujours été le cas
donc il faut un moment c'est là où il
faut mettre les mains dans le moteur et
se poser des questions pour que la
tolérance elle soit vraiment quelque
chose on enseigne la référence doit
dépasser le cadre de la lutte contre
l'homophobie la tolérance de manière
générale et de manière générale mais moi
j'ai beaucoup souffert dans les cours de
récréation de porter de particules sur
sera dans la sphère des cours pour avait
été marqué
parti sur têt jugé je vais jamais
d'autant plus fiers vont quasiment
filmée en direct son suicide il ya
quelques temps et qui passait son temps
à se faire triper des dents sur l'airé
c'est pas possible
et vous avez raison vous dis simplement
que l'invocation des valeurs dans le
public ne suffit pas
c'est à dire que il ya un moment et
c'est le problème de l'ensauvagement de
la société française aujourd'hui c'est
que les éléments et comment dire les
plus les plus simples de civilisation ne
sont pas enseignées et on est là on se
décharge de ça sur l'école voilà et il
faudrait ils doivent être partout dans
tous les courants dans tous les domaines
ce à tous les parents mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya des parents qui carrément ne
rejette ces derniers mois j'ai le plus
âgé d'entre nous tout en entendant que
surtout si on est plutôt d'accord avec
patrick l'école est-elle un dieu
pertinent pardon pour faire campagne
contre l'homophobie oui à 59%
donc vous voyez des gens jérôme jaffa le
mot de la fin
non les unités dans le duel pelloux
trémolet qui a marqué cette émission je
prends sur ce point le corps de patrick
peloux je crois qu'en effet la lutte
contre l'homophobie à l'école est
quelque chose d'essentiel
parce qu'il y à une violence extrême
entre les ados il faut le savoir parce
que derrière l'école il ya les réseaux
sociaux maintenant des insultes à
connotation sexuelle peuvent faire
atrocement souffrir des jeunes et les
mener même à des actes terribles quand
on y réfléchit donc à un rôle est
forcément l'école participe de ce combat
les réseaux sociaux s'y laisser libre
cours aux enfants aux ados qui semble
s'échangent des messages pour dire tu
sais qu'un tel est [ __ ] etc
c'est des choses qui peuvent être
terribles la l'école a réellement un
rôle à jouer et ça ne peut pas être que
la littérature et l'histoire qui nous
l'enseignent malheureusement il faut
aussi il faut il faut aussi que la
tolérance soit mise en avant mais je
suis sûr vincent trémeau n'est que sur
ce point vous êtes d'accord avec moi
merci à tous tous les cats et surtout de
ses paroles pleines de sagesse que nous
nous quittons c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui
point de vue ça me met à blaye mais
point de vue il revient dès demain par
dan bernard point de vue revient dès
demain avec la merveilleuse marie-amélie
lombard et mercredi avec l'immense
guillaume roquette bonsoir
[Musique]